well shares in facebook on a meta
plunged by around 20 percent in
after-hour trading on wednesday knocking
a massive 200 billion dollars of the
company's value
chief executive mark zuckerberg had
warned investors in a call earlier that
meta expected first quarter revenues to
decline due to competition from rivals
such as tick tock if the stock doesn't
rebound before trading resumes on
thursday it will rank as the worst day
in the company's 10-year stock market
tenure
and one of the biggest one-day falls of
any company
on record
let's get some more of this from rob
watts from dw business rob what's what's
going wrong at facebook well we're
witnessing a real turning point for the
original social media giant because for
the first time in its 18-year history
it's seeing the number of people using
its platform fall in the three months
towards the end of last year around a
million fewer people were using facebook
every day than they were
the previous three months well in the
grand scheme of facebook no it's not 1.9
billion people use facebook every day
but the thing is it's not the fact that
it is a falling number it's well that
it's a big falling number it's the fact
that it is a falling number because
facebook in its entire history has only
seen the number of people using its site
increase and why is it doing that well
mark zuckerberg's been pretty clear
about it quite frank about it really
saying that they are losing particularly
younger users to platforms like tiktok
and youtube because people's tastes are
changing and there's more bad news for
meta and that their revenues are also
slowing why is that it's because they're
making less money from advertising which
has always been a big money spinner for
them
the reason for that well there's many of
them if they're losing people obviously
using the site then they're making less
money also companies are advertising a
bit less at the moment because supply
chain problems means they're already
struggling to meet the demands that
they're currently gone the last thing
they want to do is attract more users um
but but there are also problems with
privacy as well like
privacy policies that have been
introduced for example by apple are
taking a real toll on the likes of
facebook in fact facebook reckons it's
going to take a a 10 billion dollar hit
from the apple privacy policy changes
alone this year
so
let's talk about the impact
these messages
had on on on the market yeah so as you
mentioned 20 in fact 22 wiped off the
value
of meta's shares in after hours trading
on wall street which is you know a vast
vast drop it represents as you mentioned
200 billion dollars which is bigger than
the economy of greece you know this is a
huge value drop and something that has
really spooked the market in general not
just facebook it's had a knock-on effect
for other social media we saw shares in
twitter for which we saw shares in snap4
we saw shares in pinterest all go down
because they're starting to see that if
growth is slowing at facebook then we
are really seeing a change in how people
use social media in general well that's
a good good point the face of social
media is really changing um
zuckerberg has does he have a plan for
that well
the change of the name towards the end
of last year from facebook to meta of
the parent company is a really big hint
that they're not pinning their future
hopes on the platform facebook itself
it's also a huge hint as to what they
are pinning their hopes on which is this
concept of the metaverse this virtual
reality world where we can all move
around playing meeting people working
but most importantly consuming buying
things and
that's that's a you know a great idea
and something we can all imagine
happening in the future but we are only
imagining it at the moment and it's
going to require a huge amount of
investment facebook already invested 10
billion in this concept last year but
it's going to need lots more and that
makes it a real gamble because that
investment isn't going to pay off for
many years yet
rob watts dw business thank you very
much rob